[music]
>> You have the next, the third
set of books in the Kutub al-Sittah, not
Siha Sittah. Kutub al-Sittah is Sunan
Abu Dawud.
Again, this is compiled by Imam Hafiz
Abu Dawud Sulaiman bin Ash'ath is the
full name.
And again, this
also comes in five volumes. Some of the
publishers have six volumes of Abu
Dawud. Darussalam has got five volumes
of Abu Dawud. Then you have the
Tirmidhi, Jami' al-Tirmidhi. You have
Bukhari, Muslim, then Abu Dawud, then
Tirmidhi, then you have the fifth
Sunan an-Nasa'i.
The fifth in the book of
Kutub al-Sittah. Then you have Ibn
Majah.
Sunan Ibn Majah
is the sixth book in the Kutub
al-Sittah. Some scholars,
instead of Sunan Ibn Majah,
they use Imam Malik. That's also a very
good book, authentic.
This is Al-Muwatta Malik.
So, these are mainly the Kutub
al-Sittah. I have mentioned seven. If
you read these seven, you get majority
of almost most of the rulings of fiqh,
etc. So, if a student of knowledge
learns these these six, that means yes,
you have read the most important
hadiths.
This is again, in Arabic, one volume.
All the Kutub al-Sittah in one volume.
It's heavier.
Number Darussalam, the paper used is
bible paper. Bible paper doesn't mean
Bible, because the Christian missionary
use a very expensive paper, which is
thin and light. So, they've used this
expensive thin and light paper. This is
only in Arabic, not in translation.
Yeah, again.
It is
Kutub al-Sittah, not Siha Sittah.
If you can read,
a Kutub al-Sittah, it's not Siha Sittah.
In India, it will be Siha Sittah.
Kutub al-Sittah means six books.
Siha Sittah means six authentic books.
Only Bukhari and Muslim as a whole are
authentic. In the other four books, most
are authentic, most of them. So, if
someone quotes Abu Dawud, what are you
going to do? Yes, most probably, but you
have to check whether it's sahih or not.
For that, alhamdulillah, Sheikh
Nasiruddin al-Albani has done a very
great work.
For which Sheikh Nasiruddin al-Albani
also got the King Faisal Award in the
work of literature.
What Maududi got was in service of
Islam.
What Nasiruddin al-Albani got was in
work of literature. What he did, that's
fine. You know very clearly that
everything in Bukhari and Muslim is
sahih. But if someone quotes Abu Dawud,
then someone quotes Sunan al-Nasa'i,
Tirmidhi, Ibn Majah, what are you going
to do? So, yes, compiled sahih Sunan Abu
Dawud, za'if Sunan Abu Dawud, sahih Ibn
Majah, za'if sahih Sunan al-Nasa'i, in
his compilation
of Silsalah of the Hadith.
And that is one of the great works done
by Muhaddith. Masha Allah in the last
century. And amongst the recent scholars
Shaykh Nasiruddin Albani is one of the
best as far as Hadith is concerned.
So, he has done that. So, then if
someone quotes
Abu Dawud
you have to check whether it is sahih or
not. Many a times Abu Dawud himself
mentioned in bracket it is da'if.
Well, his work wasn't to classify sahih.
His work was to collect. That's it.
He wasn't so much concerned whether it
is sahih or not. Or maybe he did little
research, didn't really do a lot. But
sometimes he collected da'if and
mentioned it as da'if also.
But majority are sahih. If someone
quotes it as a hujjah
how to offer salah and quotes from Abu
Dawud
maybe true, may not be true.
So, then you have to check up whether it
is sahih or not. And Nasiruddin Albani's
Silsalah is very good reference. Again,
scholars may differ with Nasiruddin
Albani. He's a Muhaddith and disagree.
He says it is sahih. When he says it is
sahih, it is alhamdulillah sahih. When
he says it is da'if, you know, he was
very strict. No, no, he said da'if, it's
not da'if, it is sahih. Difference of
opinion bound to be there in Muhaddith.
We not go into that.
But
this is talking about the main books of
Hadith. Then we have
Lulu'wal Marjan we discussed.
That is the Muttafaq Alayh.
Then the new edition and latest edition
which I'm doing in advance, I'd like to
tell you
that whenever I spoke about Quran and
Sahih Hadith that I'm doing it since
years.
Quran
Yeah, we have it.
No doubt. Arabic Quran, you know, will
be
pocket savior.
Arabic is much smaller Quran. No doubt.
When I say Sahih Hadith, can I bring
this full table to you?
And this Hadith also everything is out
here.
So, I used to always say Quran and Sahih
Hadith, but then
for brevity, we used to say, "Okay, two
main books."
And the Silsila of Sahih of Nasiruddin
Albani.
What to do?
So, when I say Quran and Sahih Hadith,
where is Quran? Quran is in where Sahih
Hadith?
So, okay, Sahih Hadith, okay, almost all
not almost all, but most of what's
there.
In Bukhari Muslim and the Silsila of
Sahih of Nasiruddin Albani. This concern
was there
a lot for me, but I used to use that.
Where is the Sahih Hadith? Okay, Bukhari
Muslim
and the classification of Sahih Hadith
by Albani. For me, that is
there. I used to say it's not
everything, but a good
because when you are debating and
someone wants to ask you, "What is the
authentic source?"
You have to say, "This is an authentic
source."
This was there troubling me for a long
time, but it was there. I had a
solution, part solution, until I met
alhamdulillah, the head of the
department of the Medina University of
Hadith.
That is
Dr. Sheikh Ziaur Rahman Azmi.
Professor Dr. Sheikh Ziaur Rahman Azmi.
He was the ex head and dean
of
the Hadith department
of Islamic University of Medina.
And
it was my pleasure and my honor that I
spent quite some time as to have
sessions with him for a few weeks.
And I learned a lot from him.
And many things I said come from the
sessions that I took with him.
Alhamdulillah. That is the reason even
if a Medina graduate or a PhD comes and
says, "I studied under your teacher."
So, what you can gain in that few hours
is a knowledge
which when we discuss because I like
picking things which are difficult and
the just thing which is required for my
dawa purpose. Same as the pleasure,
alhamdulillah, to spend maybe about
three, four weeks with the head of the
department of the Lughah, that is Dr.
Fadl al-Rahman who became head of the
translation department of Mujamma at the
printing press. And I learned a lot from
him. And I really mashallah review these
scholars. Alhamdulillah after he retired
retired about more than 15 years back.
And
he's a scholar.
Alhamdulillah in the last 15 years
mashallah we came up with a project
which was headed by him
and supported by us
to compile all the sahih hadith
together.
Which no one according to him has done
in the history of Islam.
According to him
there are approximately a million hadith
that are there. A million hadith.
Out of a million hadith if you remove
the duplicate
as I said his narration different
if you remove the duplicate it comes
down to approximately 60,000.
The approximate figures I'm talking
about.
When you remove the duplicate
from the million hadith you are left
with about 60,000 hadith. From this
60,000 hadith approximately
16,500
are sahih.
Only 16,500
And
when you compile the Kutub al-Sittah
and remove the duplicate like if you
remove the duplicate from Sahih Bukhari
7,275 become 2,230.
So if you compile all the hadith of
Kutub al-Sittah
it will be tens of thousands of hadith.
You remove the duplicate all together it
comes to approximately eight to eight
and a half thousand hadith.
Approximate figures.
This is estimate being a scholar.
That means amongst all the sahih hadith
only half are there in the Kutub
al-Sittah.
But these half are the most important
ones.
So, what he had been doing research
after he retired for the last 15 years,
he had two PhD students with him and he
started compiling. He said, "My mission
of life is to get this." And
alhamdulillah, we were together and we
supported the complete project, masha
Allah.
And alhamdulillah, last Ramadan,
just about 7 months back, it has been
completed.
It was completed 1 year before, but
revision and rechecking, etc. And it's
gone for printing just about 2 months
back.
It would be out
very soon.
It's not in the market yet.
But we have the soft copy.
And alhamdulillah, I have kept no
copyright on it.
So, this is the first time
in the history of Islam that all the
sahih hadith have been compiled. It's in
12 volumes.
It's being printed in 12 volumes.
It's mentioned there by Darussalam.
In this,
he has given his reasoning why he said
that it is sahih or zaif.
In this book, there is additional about
3,000 hadith which are very popular
hadith, but they are not sahih.
For example,
there's a very famous hadith of Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
that to gain knowledge, you can even go
to China.
It's commonly used by many Muslims. It's
a mawdu hadith according to Nasiruddin
Albani, mawdu.
Not zaif also. Mawdu means concocted.
There's a hadith which says that all my
sahaba are like stars. You follow any of
them,
it is okay. It's also a mawdu hadith.
Very commonly used.
Ikhtilaf is a rahmah.
Why is ikhtilaf a rahmah? Ikhtilaf can
be there. There was ikhtilaf in sahaba
without doubt. But the hadith that
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said
ikhtilaf is a rahmah is a mawdu hadith.
Is there ikhtilaf? Yes.
How can ikhtilaf be a rahmah?
It cannot.
Yes, ikhtilaf is there, that's a
different question.
But it's not a rahmah.
So many a time I have to keep quiet. At
that time I wasn't so much into
analyzing Hadith as sahih or zaif. We
were not knowledgeable that time and
neither are we now.
But now we are meeting people of
knowledge and asking them what is this.
So then we realize that Hadith is a even
mawdu and Hadith is even zaif. I'm
talking about when we started dawah.
More than 20 years back.
>> [music]
[music]